[Music]
space is full of treasures literally if
we were able to extract the resources
from the rocks in the asteroid belt
alone we could give 100 billion dollars
to every person on earth what if we
started mining them tomorrow could we
restore all of Earth's natural resources
that we've exhausted over the years how
would this change space travel and why
haven't we done it yet this is what if
and here's what would happen if we
started mining asteroids almost 800,000
asteroids are drifting untamed in the
solar system the majority of them make
up the asteroid belt between the orbits
of Mars and Jupiter but we don't have to
go that far there are 16,000 near-earth
asteroids laced with anything from gold
to water just waiting to be harvested
but even if we overcame all the
technical challenges on the weight of
these gold mines of space would we even
bring these goods back to earth
well we could bring some resources back
to earth for profit especially important
would be phosphorus zinc tin lead silver
gold and everything else that our planet
is running out of but transporting all
these precious commodities to earth in
large quantities might significantly
decrease their market value in the
planet there would be much more value in
asteroid mining if we use those
resources to further explore space sorry
Earth
we'll come back to you later with all
the water and building materials
floating untamed in our solar system
we'd have no problem colonizing the Moon
and Mars we'd send a crew to explore
Jupiter's moon Europa
and finally we travel beyond the solar
system to the billions of star systems
and exoplanets out there but back to
earth for just a moment scientists
suggest that in the early years of the
solar system when Earth was just as
lifeless as Venus asteroids were the
ones to fill our oceans with water they
were constantly hitting the young earth
bringing not only water ice but also
some complex organic molecules asteroids
made life on Earth possible and they can
make life in space possible too
imagine you are making a road trip
around Europe but there were absolutely
no gas stations along the way you'd have
to bring all your fuel with you while
traveling in space is even worse we're
trapped in the Earth's gravity it's so
strong that it takes us more energy to
escape the first 300 kilometers from
Earth than the next 300 million
kilometers it's just not efficient to
burn all that fuel for only one trip to
an asteroid on the other hand traveling
beyond Earth's gravity is almost
effortless if we started mining
asteroids we wouldn't have to carry so
much fuel around we'd be able to go
farther than we've ever imagined we'd
mine asteroids for water ice to get
water an essential element for
sustaining human life anywhere in space
water would help us maintain good
hygiene grow food and produce breathable
air it would also give us fuel we just
have to refine the water molecules into
high-efficiency propellant in a way
asteroids would be our space gas
stations they would also be our main
space supplier of building materials
we'd use asteroid metals like iron to
construct low-cost structures of any
size we want
we'd also look for precious metals like
gold silver and platinum but not to make
a ring or a necklace for our new alien
girlfriend instead to manufacture
high-end electronics spacecraft
components and laboratory equipment it's
only a matter of time before we can
extract the resources that space has to
offer first we'll need to learn more
about the asteroids and their
gravitational pulls determine what kind
of mining equipment to use and figure
out which asteroids have the most
resources to mine when we figure out the
technical side of things one question
remains who will own the asteroids what
if a company or a nation won the race to
space mining and privatize all the space
resources well expect an economic
disruption because that company our
nation would run the whole world on
earth and in space maybe instead of
mining asteroids we could terraform and
populate them but that's a topic for
another what-if
you